steam and it just so happened that
yesterday i was uh surfing youtube for
some music and i come across bruce
springsteen
uh singing a version of woody guthrie's
this land is your land i don't know if
you guys have ever heard this song
but or no woody guthrie is you you have
to know who bruce springsteen is the
boss but
woody guthrie used to run around the
country
with his guitar and folk music and on
his guitar it said this machine kills
fascists
and that was the truth woody guthrie
used his art
to tear down fascism
at every turn and if you remember the
the song god bless america woody guthrie
actually wrote this song
this land is your land in response to
that
uh because
it's not anointed to you it's all of
ours it's our land this land is our land
and that you know
and some people talk about changing the
national anthem uh from the
star-spangled banner
i this some people say imagine but i
would say that this would be at the top
of the list if that was ever a
possibility i don't know if it would be
i don't think it would be but if that
was ever a possibility this would be at
the top of this but
having said that
i think bruce
does a great version of it there's
several versions of bruce springsteen
singing this song because uh he he
absolutely loves this song and so
uh we'll we'll we'll play one version
here there is one version that i like
better where he talks in the beginning
but it's kind of long so i just want to
play the song
and the reason why i want to play the
song here's the reason why is because
everyone's a little disgruntled with the
democrats and what's going on with the
infrastructure bill and i just want to
remind you
i just want to remind you and i think
we're going to talk about it on the show
today
that
uh the unity in the country does not
need to be with fascist it doesn't and
of course you know
non the non-fascist in the country
rather you're a progressive uh if you're
a moderate if you're a democrat if
you're an anti-trump republican whatever
the case may be that unity is there it's
there it will happen we just have to
keep pushing and we have to keep pushing
against fascism not against each other i
mean of course we're going to disagree
we're not always going to agree on every
single little detail of every little
[ __ ] thing
but that's how government gets done
that's how it gets that's actually how
we do government is we don't agree
but what we can't do is take our eye off
the ball
and the eye on the ball the the prize is
to
kill fascism
kill the idea of fascism and make sure
it doesn't take power that's the idea
and if we do things that people want
even if it's not everything that every
single person wants like infrastructure
healthcare voting rights
ratifying the era there's a lot of
things we can do to make sure that
people have their liberty in this
country
without everyone getting every single
little detail that they want we need to
focus on that and i think this song
really brings that together to show you
that hey this is all of ours land and we
get to share it
now the people who are intolerant of
that [ __ ] them [ __ ] them
we do not have to tolerate the
intolerant but
we can tolerate we can't tolerate our
little differences in ideas and i think
this song does it perfectly so
having said that
let's get right to it
[Music]